how's it going bro so my name is I'm at
this uh this bar and I looks looks
pretty nice at Darren's riding bit of a
good old Swedish Swedish bar where
everyone is just nice and friendly isn't
that right
[Music]
yep that's that's totally right they
have ever been
they have great beer I love a good beer
hey hey man Oh God Oh God aah what aah
what do I do ha ha
I can't fight I'll just hide they'll
never find me what is happening guys oh
[ __ ] I killed the guy
you've done it now this is a snake guys
it was just a mistake
[Music]
alright but I'm just gonna go then
that's the scrape I'll poke your he's
dead he's definitely dead
can I get up here hey brah Oh shitty
sobbing oh so much for trying now you
stay dead don't come back up or I will
kill you if you're not dead I will kill
look at this I'm showering this is
ridiculous huh Jesus Christ you scared
the [ __ ] out of me to punch up there
live oh god it's stuck in his eyes his
name is
let's stick more things in people's
asses let's punish the bunch
Oh God top punching its crotch it's cool
to punch the back but a few if you've
punched a friend then check your front
turnbuckle holy [ __ ] what do we got in
here okay this looks oh Jesus Christ
very good good job you okay bro it's
just a prank bro oh yeah
shockwave ready what the [ __ ] does that
mean
holy crap that was awesome
I moose I'm doing it for you there was
something on moose we found water on
moose no way how do I get up there sorry
guys
sorry let's borrow
goddammit the me Devon oh I got it I got
a go of the knife what are you doing
breath holy crap I cut off his legs
that's amazing
I ride I ride all right I like to do
they don't mind me I just want to get
them that young French [ __ ] you know
what I mean that's let me kill him that
yes we can kill him but it starts so it
starts to be a killing dance block
ain't no Potter like put a paw paw
together I have no idea what's going on
[Music]
[Applause]
amen
oh my god I got a pimp I got a [ __ ]
pimp stick
hey I go oh god I'm so sorry Kentucky
[ __ ] quad kill okay I like him you're
saying it's right to buskers see I knew
Jesus don't do anything playing itself
okay well if you're interested in this
game I look for the camera cuz I changed
it I'm like wait check it out and have
some fun support the developer and
hopefully the game will keeps getting
updated more more weapons would be cool
more levels more if the if some weapons
were more durable maybe a crafting
system I don't I don't know that's all
for me for now thank you for watching
and I'll see you bros and the next one
as always stay awesome press let's
pretend that we're a school MA and we
need to drive our kids to school and
we're really [ __ ] short on time my god
we made that jump like a [ __ ] boss